one of the stars of the Twilight
franchise has a pretty dark outlook on
our experiences during filming Anna
Kendrick who played the small supporting
role of Jessica Stanley a high school
classmate and friend of protagonist
Bella Swan played by Kristen Stewart
recently filmed a career breakdown video
for Vanity Fair's YouTube channel and
admitted she had a miserable time
filming Twilight Kendrick didn't spend
much time on screen during the Twilight
Saga which was based on the equally
popular series of supernatural teen
romance novels by Stephenie Meyer
apparently however the experience still
wasn't particularly positive according
to Kendrick the cold and hostile weather
was a big factor which makes sense
considering that the series was filmed
in the rainy Northwest city of Portland
Oregon she remembers being on set with
her converse sneakers completely soaked
through during the shoot and remembers
thinking to herself you know this is a
really great group of people and I'm
sure that we would be friends in a
different time but I want to murder
everyone she does however have a
positive spin on her time on set saying
it was actually a bonding experience for
the cast and crew you know like you go
through like some trauma event like you
imagine like people who survive like a
hostage situation you're gonna bond it
brulee in the video in which Kendrick
details performances from her debut in
the cult classic film camp to her
starring role in the pitch-perfect films
she remembers how she got into the
Twilight Saga in the first place and
what her experience was like on all four
films apparently getting the role at all
was a complete surprise yeah I got that
job which was I mean truly like such a
shock as she remembers she was asked to
audition after director Catherine
Hardwicke saw her in a Sundance Film
Mackendrick considered it to be a blow
off audition since she couldn't picture
being cast as what she called a mean
girl character I just thought like well
no su as well as I can so that the
casting director like thinks of me for
other stuff when it came to the second
movie Kendricks memories were slightly
fonder
thanks to slightly better weather and
more of a chance to get to know her
co-workers and luckily the project
didn't prevent her from working on buzzy
or prestige projects like up in the air
which earned her an Academy
or denomination she explained I was
shooting up in the air by the time we
were making that second movie so they
rearranged a lot of scheduling stuff it
would have been a real move but legally
they had the right to stop me from doing
up in the air so shout-out to those guys
Kendricks Twilight memories are a pretty
mixed bag especially as the franchise
increased her role on the heels of her
Oscar nomination discussing the third
film eclipse Kendrick says they all
start to blend into one at some point
because my whole job was to go like this
family of very pale people who we never
see eating they're really weird right
in fact Kendrick had some trouble
remembering what she even did in the
third film free Kendrick went into
detail about that particular scene
saying I remember thinking like why did
they make my character the valedictorian
she's very obviously not a good student
but they just wanted me to have
something to do because it was a speech
I just did what was scripted and I swear
that scene people are like you know that
speech you give in that third movie it's
really sweet it's really moving and I
swear to god I'm like the thing that is
happening is you are looking at Kristen
Stewart's reaction to that speech and
that is the thing that is moving you
Kendrick was also briefly featured in
the fourth movie during which bad
weather struck again it was just like a
wedding scene where again I'm like
people are so weird and you're in like
just frozen mud Kendrick has become one
of Hollywood's most popular young stars
since her time in the Twilight franchise
and apparently it's pretty firmly in her
rearview mirror I hope I was less
pretentious than you're expecting check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]